now the goal of this evening's series is
to introduce our friends to the
excitement of brain research soon to be
housed the Jerome L green Sciences
Center now if some of you have joined us
before for some reasons we are delighted
to have you here
I mean this is your first time if we
have that in a small way we can help you
capture some of the magic
now understanding the human brain is the
greatest scientific challenge of this
century how is it that this organ that
weighs less than two percent of your
body weight yet consumes 30 percent
energy transform the human condition and
turns sadness into happiness fear into
courage conformity into creativity and
of course despair our goal the Mortimer
Zuckerman mine brain and behavior is to
transform these abstract concepts into
the language of biology what's the plan
to bring together and to recruit the
brightest wildest craziest most
ingenious minds and to let them loose in
this new environment to help transform
our understanding of the human brain now
tonight is a very special event in
particular because we will have two very
special guests these are the
philanthropic visionaries that helped
transform an idea and initiative into a
reality and first I'd like to thank
Chris McInerney yes of the Jerome L
green foundation for giving us such a
wonderful home the Jerome ilgwon I will
later when Mort shows up acknowledge
Moore's terrific contribution to this
now what about tonight
so I wish total playing in the fourth
century that the function of the brain
was to serve as a secondary organ to
warm and cool the heart
and serve as a place where it this
spirit can circulate free extra here we
have a statement that now 24 plus
centuries later we can use to define the
very essence also of jazz an organ to
warm and cool the heart and a place
where your soul can circulate free and
that is the plan for this evening now
the master of ceremonies tonight is
going to be Michael shuttling professor
of brain sciences that exemplifies the
very essence of what we want to do to
bring brilliant minds that transit
parallel worlds science and art to help
us get to the core of what it means to
be human
and what it means to have a brain so
Michael is a scholar in the study of
brain circuits and decision-making but
today is going to wear two different
hats where it's going to use this
understanding of neuroscience to
translate some of what we perceive as
the soul of music into the language of
the brain
well Charles thank you so much thank you
for calling the human and saying I have
a brain this is the two nicest things
anyone has ever said okay we're good so
I'd like to thank you all for
participating what I hope will be a
dialogue it's a dialogue between artists
and scholars and scientists the artist
scholar in particular Chris Washburn on
the faculty at Columbia in fact the
entire band is a Columbia faculty band
it's going to be a dialogue between
musicians among each other in the
process of creating jazz a creation in
the moment in the now as they say and
between us you will you and me in the
band and it'll be about idea ideation
creation and comprehension now I'm going
to tell you a little about myself I'm a
neurologist and a neuroscientist I have
an abiding interest and what it is about
the brain that constructs the creates
that gives rise to thought but also why
those processes fail in certain diseases
and how we can do better to remedy the
situation for our patients now I think
there's reason to believe that a small
set of principles or call the mechanisms
underlying our of mental operations that
we loosely refer to as cognitive
something that lies between sensation
and action that's the stuff of thought
and I think that the breakdown of these
fundamental processes also holds the key
to understanding how the mechanisms that
are responsible for disease at the
molecular genetic level give rise to the
manifestations of disease at the
psychiatric behavioral psychological
level we want to know that because
ultimately we'd like to treat disorders
of thought reasoning memory
socialization lumping a lot of disorders
of higher brain function
we'd like to treat those by intervening
at a level of the nervous system that
you could say is the answer to
question what is it about a normal brain
that makes it not confused now my own
research is about that problem and I
study I study the problem of how we make
decisions and so when this woman is
facing this fork in the road she's
working it out and she's working out the
her ideas about what might be at the end
of each of those paths the cost of
spending time before rather than you
know waiting for more information to
maybe make a better decision thinking
about what the future might be using
memory what psychologists call
prospecting imagining that if she makes
it to the end of a path how costly might
it be to come back and check out the
other way and if there's a reward or
some kind of failure along the way what
does she want to learn about the path
not taken now all of those processes
enter the mind and we'd like to
understand exactly how and you can say
you you you can see why I think that
decision-making even simple decisions
about left and right paths turn out to
give us insight into cognition in
general so I like to think about
studying decision-making as a window on
cognition and I think that as josé
Saramago said that it's not so much that
we make decisions but decisions make us
meaning that it essentially defines who
we are even our character and our status
as moral agents so I think what we're
studying is something in some sense
larger than brain mechanisms we're
studying who we are okay so that gets me
a little bit closer to what we're about
to embark into on tonight which is a
dialogue about music and about jazz in
particular now you know when an animal
forages meaning leaves the nest to go
look for some maybe something better
someplace else they go through a lot of
the same kinds of steps that I just
described so I view that is a kind of an
evolutionary rudimentary process that
allows us to see maybe deeper into the
brain
level of the biology what it takes to
make a decision and it makes
decision-making a tractable problem now
we talked about foraging and exploring
and I don't mean - exploring exploring
capriciously but explore exploring and
some directed way asking sort of
directed questions will that path work
out or not not let's flip a coin and
figure out which path to take
then where we begin to start thinking
about a connection to creativity and
improvisation I like this quote from
Wynton Marsalis he said in jazz
improvisation isn't a matter of just
making any old thing up you know it's
not like this woman's not flipping a
coin about which way to go
jazz like any language has its own
grammar vocabulary there's no right or
wrong just some choices that are better
than others now what I'm going to do
tonight with you and with Cris is we're
going to we're going to discuss of some
some neuroscience and I'm going to show
you
neurons and things like that but I think
before I get too carried away why don't
I bring out the band and why don't we
play some music for you all right
I'm a little on the shaky side Chris can
you tell us a little bit about whe what
the audience just heard and maybe
introduce the van please my pleasure to
be here tonight and to have this
dialogue in front of all of you and
share our worlds worlds a little bit and
see where they collide and collude with
neuroscience but before we do that I
just want to take a moment to introduce
these fine musicians I have up on stage
with me as Mike said they're all faculty
members and the Louis Armstrong jazz
performance program at Columbia
University someone who's the assistant
director to the program and also the
saxophone instructor as well as one of
the most original voices on the tenor
saxophone in New York City playing with
everybody and you can imagine the
fabulous limit Eason
on bass a gentleman who teaches bass at
Columbia University he's also really one
of the busiest bass players in New York
City that I know of as a matter of fact
if you like what you hear now and you
want to hear more you can just go down
the street to the Village Vanguard and
he's playing there tonight
starting at 8:30 with Tom Harrell the
fabulous who got a vocabulary and also
an amazing versatile musician that I've
been playing with for many years someone
who plays at Jazz at Lincoln Center with
Whitmarsh Ellis at play has played with
Arturo Farrell still and with the Ray
Barretto band for many many years and
also plays with poquito de Rivera and
actually got his start playing with the
Mamas and the Papas believe it or not
the fabulous Vince Cherico so I just
want to take a moment before we get back
to neuroscience to talk about jazz and
what I mean by that and what I like to
do is turn to some of the founding
fathers and mothers of this music and
take note of how they defined it and
what they said about it and the first
person I want to quote is somebody named
Sidney Bechet someone that was very
important in New Orleans wonderful
clarinetist he's the reason why we have
saxophone and jazz to begin with who's
the first one to bring that in and when
asked about jazz and what it was he said
it's the sound of freedom it's the
freedom that the emancipated slaves
found and they had to make sense of that
newfound freedom they had to create
something beautiful out of ugliness they
had to transform use the materials at
hand and improvise a new way of life so
for Bechet it was a philosophy of life
it was way of being it was a way of
navigating it was a way of getting
through at the same time this question
about what is jazz continues gets asked
even after 120 years of this music and
just recently Wayne Shorter one of the
most famous musicians we have alive
wonderful tenor saxophone player was
asked what does jazz mean to you he says
means I dare you now what's interesting
about both of these definitions neither
one of these musicians are treating jazz
as an object or as a noun
their verb affine the word I know other
words it's an action it's a way of being
it's a way of navigating through life
and at the center of that is
improvisation
now improvisation is a very interesting
thing because it doesn't just exist in
jazz as a matter of fact it is the
center of existence human beings it
provides every single day and if you
didn't you'd be dead I'll prove it today
as you're walking to this wonderful
event
you crossed 7th Avenue well you started
to and you put your foot out and you
look and you saw a bus coming what did
you do you improvised and step back
therefore you're alive we also improvise
when we have conversations on the street
when we see somebody that we haven't
seen for a while we say hello and they
say hello back and then we ask one of
the most dangerous questions in the
entire universe
how you doing because at that moment we
don't know what they're gonna say and we
engage in improvisation and indeed when
we engage with people when we say how
you doing and they say something that
surprises us we delve deeper and engage
deeper what jazz musicians did in the
beginning and still do is they use these
fundamental concepts of human survival
and daily interaction and create an art
form out of it and so how we do that as
we create spontaneously before your eyes
as a band we have never ever played
together before until right now
we've played individually with each
other but this is the first time that
you're seeing so not only did you see
the rehearsal you saw the dress
rehearsal and also the performance right
before your eyes
unfolding that's what jazz is
so you guys might want to sit relax
gonna so I'm gonna share a little bit of
neuroscience with you and try to make a
connection to between thought and art in
general and I think we'll try and bring
it closer to jazz via Chris's expertise
so the way I think about it I've already
introduced the concept that our brains
are undergo a kind of directed
exploration now I'm going to say that we
do that in situations where it's not
even obvious let me give you an example
I mean I'm gonna what I'm gonna bring
you through our two concepts about
prediction and resolution and time is an
archetype aesthetic I'll explain what I
mean so here's a picture
my son thirty years ago and I'm gonna
fool your brains into seeing some motion
now this is just a film loop but most of
you are seeing him kind of expand yeah
here's another one same same starting
picture but it's a four frame loop and
you're probably seeing clockwise
rotation Y without getting into details
because we know something about how the
brain processes motion and we put a
little energy out there that you will
interpret as a little bit of motion and
then what the brain does is it doesn't
just process it it doesn't just do
information processing with deep
learning and google's yada yada what it
does is it makes a hypothesis about
where something might be a moment later
in this case centrifugal II expanding
from the center and it gets right it
gets a confirmation of that and you see
that as expansion despite the illogical
fact that luckily Josh did not in fact
explode and in this case same thing
except that the motion you're being
enticed to interrogate is a little bit
of a displacement in a clockwise
direction you get a little bit of a of a
feedback a little confirmation a
resolution of that prediction that your
brain made and you continue to sort of
see this as rotation now you might get
sick when I stop this so be careful
because you get pretty bad after effect
most people do okay so um that's what I
wanted to show you
I think in the interest of time I might
show this illusion to you at the end if
we have time that we can get back to the
music a little quicker now sorry we'll
come back to them time I would argue
time is really the key to thought now in
my lab when we study decision-making and
we do this by recording from neurons and
brains of animals what we noticed is
that in the big parts of the brain that
connect the sensory information to the
what are we going to do about it in
other words as I said before the stuff
of thought that intervenes between
information processing and actually
using that information believing in it
deciding that these neurons have a sense
of time in fact we just have a paper
that came out today about this topic and
it's kind of interesting that they have
a sense of time they don't have time
sense and like a clock does they have a
time sense in an anticipation way okay
so again the sense that something is
predicted to occur in the near future
say I'm ganas playing a note and I have
a sense because his time sense is so
amazing that the next one's gonna come
at some point but we're he swings it a
little bit and it's a little bit delayed
or a little bit anticipatory and makes
this you know shiver a little bit you
know it's all subtle right but what our
brains are sensing that predicting when
things are going to occur next well I
want to show you a very simple
demonstration it's the only science
thing I'm going to do really in terms of
showing you brain things but you're
going to get to hear we did title this
the sounds of science and one of those
sounds is that when we record electrical
activity from the brain we can play it
to you through a loudspeaker like it's
music it's not very pretty music it just
sounds like a bunch of clicks I'm gonna
play you that because it's a think it's
a fun thing to get to listen to cells in
the brain do the stuff of thought so
this is a very simple experiments
probably the simplest one we've ever
done in my lab and what we do is we ask
the animal to time and interval sees a
spot now sees the second spot
and the deal is when this spot dims the
first one make an eye movement to that
second spot okay that's it now the thing
is the amount of time he's waiting for
comes is random sometimes it's a second
that's the most common time that's what
this graph is showing you it's never
more than two seconds it's never less
than a half a second and this is sort of
the kind of probabilities that that are
sampled animal gets to know that gets
into the structure of the time that of
the environment okay just as we do we
play music in another context here's the
trick we show him times that are short
like around a half a second we never
show him times around a second and we
also show times around two seconds so
the technical term for this is a bimodal
distribution it has two modes one around
1/2 second one around 2 ok same thing
happens now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to show you what a neuron in the
brain does when when the animal knows
that it's very likely things are going
to occur in that first mode something
around a second and what I'm going to do
is I'm going to show you a case where
you had to wait around for a second and
a half and what I hope you hear I'm kind
of I'm sort of leading the witness here
but what I hope you hear is that the
activity of this neuron these clicks
you're going to hear on the loudspeaker
if everything works right are going to
increase in frequency and intensity as
if the brain is is anticipating this the
arrival of this go signal that's listen
the increase in the frequency a bit like
a crescendo but it's more of a crescendo
that Vince would do you know rattling
away now let's consider another one now
we go to that other context and in this
context the animal knows that time
doesn't ever happen at a second it's
always the leader short or it's long and
with a little random randomness around
either of those times and once again
we're going to ask okay what happens if
he's sitting around waiting for one of
those long times what's the brain doing
as the waiting is going on and again
just to sort of feed you the intuition
is that maybe anticipating
early but if that doesn't come then stop
anticipating and then anticipate again
so kind of a triphasic rise fall rise
again okay so see what see if you can
hear that in this recording of a neuron
in the brain came up it went down and it
came up again everyone okay so that's
what you're hearing is a cell in the
brain that's keeping track of time
why because keeping track of time is
what makes us be able to think it makes
us infer cause and effect as a child
something hits the floor and then the
noise comes okay and so forth or you did
something silly and then the pain comes
okay so we have to learn about the
structure of time and I would say that
in general time is sort of the core of
higher brain function and I'm going to
say in a moment the aesthetic so I like
to think about the this secret of
thought of cognition or really many many
many mental processes is a kind of
freedom from immediacy the need to use
information not on the timeframe of the
immediate changes in the world around us
and not in the immediate now timeframe
imposed by having to control our bodies
that's it's just an it's an engineering
problem a really interesting one but
thought resides again between those two
extremes and it must have freedom from
immediacy and in many disorders I'm
thinking you know many patients that I
treated in my neurology days that
involve global confusion what happens is
there's a failure of this mechanism to
be able to keep information through on
the order of seconds like this example
or maybe longer tens of seconds and
think about it if you can't if
information was just to come into the
brain and have to die away instantly if
it didn't cause an action there would be
no way to make sense in any flexible way
beyond a reflexive sense there would be
no way to make any sense of the past
connecting to the present connecting to
the future okay we'd be hopelessly
confused okay and that's what that's
what happens to people unfortunately
okay now I want to bring it back to the
aesthetic in the more place of new
so when I'm trying to tell you the
hypothesis or the thesis is that thought
is a kind of directed exploration it
involves a prediction and some kind of
resolution of that prediction and time I
just gave you as an example is sort of
an archetype it's AB it's paradigmatic
for this basic property which is true of
lots of things it's true when we looked
at that movie of the rotating baby okay
there was some sense that our brains
were led to predict something and it was
the fulfillment of that prediction that
led us to in this case the illusory
sense that that baby was rotating now I
would say there's one extra thing I'll
throw out and then I need to hear Chris
on this and that is the the the step
that's missing into my mind that gets us
to the esthetic to art is that the
artist is imbuing a sense of
anticipation in the beholder in an arts
case the listener and you and and by
maybe exploring outside the key playing
with the time teasing a bit and creating
a little of tension before maybe
resolving coming into the beat or
returning to the key Center that's the
essence of what in music we would say
makes something interesting at least and
that necessarily pretty maybe it's maybe
it's even ugly but interesting and
artful and we could talk about the same
thing I had the pictures of the dancers
up there where gravity seems to imply a
certain resolution but there's a certain
defiance of it and then it resolves in
painting we could make the same kind of
statements about about curvature and
forms that tie down our sense of
expectation but then there's some
tension and release I love this quote
from Dave Leoben who was a jazz
he's an NEA Jazz Master right and so art
is constant tension and release this
that's where the artists live between
two or at times or between the two right
sorry or at times submerge in either I
think that's a really interesting way to
think about jazz
so look what I just said I think it's
about a general statement about the
aesthetic and trying to relate it to the
kind of brain science that again
interests me in part because ultimately
I see it as the key to understanding
higher brain function and curing disease
that's you know my motivation but it was
sort of a generic sense of the aesthetic
there and I'd like to hear so Chris like
like what is special about the Jazz part
of that well personally I'm interested
in what you have to say but I'm more
interested in world peace and happiness
and I think that I'm against it Chris I
think I think that also lies in time but
also the plain of time and also the not
in the notion that it's not only tension
and resolution but it's also love and
fear and those play very important roles
in jazz musicians lives and in terms of
our aesthetic but in order for us to be
able to do this what we have to do is we
have to fix ourselves and in place
ourselves in the present and nowhere
else our relation to time is just truly
present but indeed we manipulate it and
we manipulate the perception for various
effect and to try to make the music
compelling but the idea is that to be
fully present to be nowhere else where
there's no other thoughts is where
blissful moments lie it's what
psychologists call the state of flow
when you're so into whatever activity
you are into that you lose track of time
and that you lose track of almost
yourself as you delve deeply into it
it's the moments of our most happiest
moments in life usually it happens
during sex it happens during an
incredible conversation with somebody it
happens when we create and we improve
and build something and make things and
so in order for us to do this
collectively though and not individually
some things have to be in place that is
fully present with each other in other
words when people oftentimes ask us what
do you think about when you play music
what do you think about when you're
taking a solo and you're improvising
well the real answer is nothing Wayne
Shorter said I imagine the world what it
could be and what it should be in other
words nothing he's just interacting with
the sounds around him and his emotion
he's he trying to communicate with the
audience and that's what we're trying to
do as well and with each other and in
order to be able to do that we have to
develop some very deep listening skills
listening skills that a lot of people
don't practice in their daily lives I
remember the first time that I was in
college my first class my assignment and
my teacher was Richard Davis a wonderful
jazz bassist the first assignment was to
go out and listen to a concert that
night I was like wow damn I like college
I don't have to read a book I don't have
to write anything I just have to go to
hear music and he was like no I want you
to go and really listen and like well of
course I'm gonna listen what am I gonna
do sit there and fall asleep he goes no
I want you to listen so hard you sweat
and I thought about what could that
possibly mean can you imagine what it
would be like to be so connected that
you're sweating and you're listening
that deeply which means you're not only
listening to the sounds but you're
listening to the emotions the spirit and
all of the intentions around you
simultaneously there's no more space for
anything else with that kind of
connectedness I'll show you what it's
like well would you like to know what
it's like to be a jazz musician well
whether you do or not I like to try an
exercise with you if you have something
on your lap if you could just place it
on the floor or or on this on the side
and I'm just gonna have you do a short
little exercise I'm gonna give you a
series of instructions but I don't want
you to
do the instructions until I tell you the
first thing is that I'm gonna raise them
the first thing is that I'm gonna clap a
rhythm what I want you to do is I want
you to listen to that rhythm when you
feel comfortable I want you to join me
okay
okay anytime you're back good don't rush
right with me
the secret of grooving collectively is
to relax and to smile nice now I'm gonna
stop clapping but you can't because
you're the drummer in the band right now
so you must keep going no matter what
you do not stop clapping I want you to
listen to those around you and see if
you can hear them clapping with you this
whole room should sound like just one
person clapping that's right you make
that adjustment you negotiate you're
manipulating time you're anticipating
the time you don't stop clapping
whatever you do if been stopped playing
in the middle the music would stop okay
now I'm gonna give you another set of
instructions without stopping clapping
and without losing the groove I want you
to turn to the person that's closest to
you not yet and you're gonna ask them
what their favorite color is now they're
gonna respond what it is and why and
they have to use a complete sentence and
then when they are done you're gonna
switch and they're gonna ask you what
your favorite color is the whole time
not losing this groove ready go
everybody get back to the groove and
stop
now I just want to take a moment for you
to reflect on how you feel right now
some of you are relieved that you're
stopping clapping you have some sore
hands I realize that but I also I'm
seeing a lot of smiles and I'm seeing a
lot of bright eyes even brighter than
they were before we started why
because I forced you to be nowhere but
here because your brain doesn't have the
ability to do more than what I requested
you had to keep time you had to listen
around you you had to respond to my
instructions and then I really forced
you to improvise because I highly doubt
you had an answer prepared about what
your favorite color was and you didn't
expect that that's what I was going to
ask you to do so you actually had to
form a duet and interact with one
another
that's what jazz musicians do when they
play they have to get to that place the
only difference is is our conversation
is with five separate people
simultaneously as opposed to just one
sitting next to you so maybe we should
play another tune and do you guys want
to clap while we play no please don't do
that but but maybe we could do something
else though and see the band these guys
I mean you know these these people are
just incredible and they communicate I
don't know if you heard all the
communication going on in turnaround the
tune we played first but we'll play a
slower tune now right and and see if you
can catch the back-and-forth and the
exchange of ideas that goes on during
this tune
it's a Thelonious Monk tune called round
about midnight
well do any of you have any questions
you'd like to ask about the band about
the music about what happens other
neuroscience anything you like anything
that's on your mind thank you that was
very nice yeah great yeah I'm just
curious so you you discussed this idea
of one of the basis of cognition being I
think the term used was freedom from
immediacy right
whereas I felt like what Chris was
saying about his about music and about
you know what he feels when he plays
music is almost the exact opposite of
that is a freedom to engage in sort of
the immediacy of the experience so I was
wondering if you could talk a little bit
about that and well I think that the two
are compatible I mean the what allows us
to use the information at various levels
not just the next beat the measures the
phrases the section the cadence is using
the past in order to inform where we
hope the future is going to go including
when we're creating the future with an
improvisation now of course I think
Chris is just spot-on
with the idea that we have to do that in
time in music and we in a sense
experience its so immediately in the now
that it just you know it brings us right
there there's no it's there's something
very special I think Chris rose to the
challenge what's special about jazz and
what's special about jazz it makes it
different from literature or you know
having a conversation with your friend
and all of these things happen when we
do that doing mathematics we have a
sense of completion we complete it we
work through the proof later in our mind
it had a sense of completion before we
started yeah but there's something very
special about jazz where things are
really right there then I don't know I I
don't get to do this very much and I
mean to be able to play with these guys
it's just like it's such an incredible
treat you have no idea I watched these
guys in clubs all the time but that's
what they're doing it with the sounds
and the idea is it's just it's it just
takes you to a different place and I
mean so thank you guys because you've
just taken me to a different place so I
also I also think that to respond to
your question is that I love to disagree
with Mike but I actually we have to
think about two different sets senses of
immediacy because one thing that I've
learned with my conversations that Mike
is the time in the neuroscience sense
it's a little bit different than what
how we actually experience and so when
in in some ways we have to be fully
present but what's happening in our
brains actually when we're improvising
there are there is time there there is
delay and it's a different sense of time
that seems to be happening with those
electronic respect Racal responses yes
in the back
has it happened really has anyone
noticed those sour notes sorry
well there is it's a great question what
I mean the brain is always learning
right from its experience it's including
the experiences we create and I
mentioned this we know the woman's going
down that path and presumably with what
happens during that path might might be
informative to which path to go down the
next time she's in that same kind of a
situation and there is this sense of
expectation of a completion I think it's
a bit like the expecting expecting
reward we find some satisfaction when
the tension is resolved when the key
comes back when the beat does land after
maybe playing a little bit with the time
and and when we when we ups and we don't
hit what we meant when someone fooled us
you may might hear that as a little
humor we might hear that as yet another
built in more tension that thing that
Dave Liebman said the that sort of
living both in the tension and the
release simultaneously but but the brain
does it does have a very strong activity
that we don't fully understand when an
oops occurs and in fact the difference
between people who wake up from coma and
the people who remain in coma can be
sensed with EEG electrodes now based on
the presence or absence of kind of a
high level
OUP's signal because they're there in
their in that moment there of creating
predictions the brain is about what's
going to happen next I can answer that
question from a jazz musicians brain is
that you have to understand that our
mandate in our profession is to every
time we go to work create something new
and we have to do that in front of an
audience so that means that peril is
just around every single musical phrase
and every single note that we play but
we have a very different relationship to
ups and failure than I think other
segments of society and that is we take
that as an opportunity and the mistakes
that happen in jazz is when when you
don't capitalize on those mistakes
because it's when you play the wrong
note that all the sudden the musicians
now need to contend with that new sound
and what do we do with it that's the
moment when we actually create something
new
so I'm gonna stop the questions because
we have to we'll have to we have to
close the set very soon and I think it
mean it might be nice to play one more
tune is that okay any the thing is some
of us will hang around and answer your
questions anyway and of course this is a
dialogue really as I said and the
dialogue continues what we're doing here
is it's not just the dialogue among
musicians it's not just a dialogue among
columbia people and it's a dialogue with
the community as well and we're going to
Kris and I are part of trying to
establish a scholar slash
artist-in-residence program at the new
Jerome Green Science Center and the
Zukerman mind brain behavior Institute
where people we will have this kind of
interaction that interaction will
include our neighbors in the in the
community and which i think is it's just
the right home for jazz in in new york
and so we Allah you can we'd love to
hear your input on those kinds of things
and we'll discuss with you how the brain
works okay that was written just a few
blocks from the new building and it was
really about communication a
communication across scholars I mean
across cultures amongst musicians and
deep thinkers about this music and I'm
talking about a song that was played and
one of Duke Ellington's band one of his
biggest hits but it was not written by
him and this is something called caravan
written by want ease all the first
Puerto Rican to be hired into his band
and this is about their many journeys
meeting lots of different types of
cultures and bringing those types of
musics in to have a broader global
conversation we hope you enjoy
Vince Jericho on the drums you gonna get
low on the bass pull them a teasing on a
saxophone and mike shanin on the guitar
yeah thank you so much
never works together and we try to get
in to do an experiment now before I
close it I want to thank our second
great philanthropic position and that's
a truly for giving us the opportunity to
engage in the exploration but what we do
as the boldest and greatest scientific
journey
a journey into the center of our
memories emotions actions
so on behalf of everyone the Mortimer
Zuckerman mind brain behavior incident
at the Jerome l3 Sciences Center we like
to once again thank Mort and Chris and
thank you all for being here and I hope
you'll get to see you soon where
musicians will talk about neuroscience